presented by the boys taking the fight
to superheroes on Amazon Prime video on
July 26th
[Music]
before he Reeves
but before heroes and even before he and
Robin Batman returned in its as Batman
Returns you guys after Tim Burton it
wanders a solid by making Batman cool
again they'll let him get his freak on
in the sequel with all the burden in
cities you know and love plus a dash of
Frank Miller grit a touch of Adam West's
silliness and two scoops of the Batman
xxx porn parody avoid teacher my french
trick hey creep children are watching
this movie about a violent billionaire
who beats up poor people and by beats up
I mean kills
he'll be fine you think this is a Batman
movie think again because he is not in
it very much Michelle Pfeiffer stars as
Selina Kyle a strong confident woman
only after a traumatic brain injury and
winter corpse gets bitten by a
radioactive cat or something she'll
become Catwoman I am an antihero who
loves licking lounging and long
drawn-out gymnastics routines
man she's so good in this can we get a
so Catwoman movie please no no I take it
back I take it back
tired of comic book movies where the
whole universe is at stake return to the
glory days when heroes fought over what
really matters local municipal politics
watch Bruce Wayne engage in a proxy war
over electing a new mayor who will grant
a rival billionaire some construction
permits or something but we're gonna
break ground when we gotta break ground
now I'll need permits variances tax
incentives would fight you on this and
I've already spoken to the mayor who
almost makes you miss a sky beam but
where the plot stumbles the villains
personalities shine as Christopher
Walken earns the title of cinemas second
best Shrek and Danny DeVito brings a
manic unhinged fury to the penguin a
[Applause]
mutant with a wide arsenal of umbrellas
and an even wider arsenal of disturbing
little broad noises our real Penguins
this nasty did Morgan Freeman lie to us
but there's got to be some Batman in
this Batman movie somewhere and when
Bruce Wayne isn't snacking in front of a
TV cooled or begging the world to learn
his secret identity
he'll hit the streets to bust some heads
whether they're clowns clowns on stilts
clowns with machine guns or slowly
advancing karate clowns no clown is safe
from Batman's vengeance wait so let me
get this straight
the penguin gets penguins and the clown
army and the Joker gets Bob that's fair
so suit up with the film that changed
the course of the bad franchise by
grossing out the sponsors so much they
gave the next two movies to Joel
Schumacher the man everyone hates we're
making Batman too kinky too jokey a
floor high fiber and just way too campy
it's like you just didn't respect the
source material you know
Batman has always been serious business
you guys serious business starring The
Bachelor Cat Scratch Pfeiffer love
Bachelor the toxic avenger
why was the funeral march of the
Penguins
a posse of insane clowns adopt don't job
and who needs a Catwoman when you got
yourself a caddy man sometimes it's a
most of the time it's a waste of time
must you be the only lonely man beast in
town so we changed the channel 4
programme with some dignity
I suppose you feel better now sir great
I think I'll take the stairs
may we RSVP'd not interested although
this way nakiya might be there the dark
nightmare before christmas props to the
actor playing walking sun for doing a
walk impression to his face that golf
aim yourself
this episode was brought to you by the
boys a new series on Amazon Prime video
premiering on July 26th I'm a boy
watching the boys storm area 51 they
can't stop us all
what's my name suck it that's my name